[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
what is happening
hello welcome back to the break room
this is our daily we have headphones in
they're too loud that's where I'll use
it I need to react uh Breakers and
roomies in the chat out there welcome
back to the break room this is our daily
live show that keeps you updated on all
the nerdy news you need to know yes
coming up today we have some more
updates from ccxp and also some exciting
Daredevil Born Again casting okay what
is that news you have to stick around to
find out before we get to all that news
I'm Brandon who cares at the end of the
table ladies and gentlemen he hasn't
left us yet master taming himself hello
everybody in the building every one of
you where's the camera is it you yes I
love you he loves you all winking hold
on yes we're so happy to have you here
in Our Mysterious City that will never
reveal what it is next Mt we got the
beautiful Jessica Clemens
[Music]
Saucy Saucy and right next to me it's
Tommy B boy the weather in Butte Montana
perfect for making news uh I forgot to
mention yesterday I know it's a tough
time for a lot of our viewers because
the Thanksgiving leftovers people hurled
into their homes slash dumpsters are
probably gone now or have turned so a
lot of you are going through a tough
time with uh uncertainty as to whether
or not your dumpster will have coverage
during this cold winter months and I
just want to say trash bags let my
commentary be a blanket a blanket to
swaddle you when you are down yeah
that's very kind of you Tommy even
though you insiduated that they live in
dumpsters or oh I have proof I have the
receipts I have the research I've done
my own research 98 of our chat lives in
dumpsters oh my goodness
rat bones they Feast on rat bones
well speaking of rat bones we have a
great Redemption for you folks today
no no don't don't encourage him don't
you encourage uh for every 100 we raise
in super chats we will be reading some
AI MCU script that's right artificial
intelligence that has been programmed to
make us scripts yeah well let's just say
producer John well okay with this money
I came in he had a big grin on his face
if you know him yes something's up he
was like I envisioned a suit of armor
around the world also funny scripts yes
he was wearing a Skynet shirt as well he
he is excited he's like through the dark
web which I'm frequently on obtaining
goods and services I have acquired an AI
program that can write scripts and I was
like John this seems dangerous and he's
like well let me just show you so he
made me this little script would you
like to play Picard yeah yeah is it okay
oh do you want to do it oh sure yeah
okay I mean I mean it would just be
we're just giving this one for free so I
don't know why you'd immediately make a
different but I guess you guys can no no
no yes you take over the show that's why
I gave it to you I don't think they're
looking for accent accuracy here
if we raise a hundred dollars send in
super chats of like what you'd like to
see in these prompts the prompts we put
in was uh Professor Xavier and John Luke
Picard play chess yes okay so it's a
little snippet created by the machine
take it away it says interior Xavier
school day Charles Xavier and Jean-Luc
Picard sit across from each other at a
chessboard you can be Xavier okay
Luke it's been so long since we've had a
game of chess indeed Charles I'm looking
forward to a good match as am I me Shall
We Begin let's the other two men begin
to play they move their pieces around
the board each one carefully considering
their next move wow wait let me you're
playing quite well Jean this is jungle
thank you Charles I must say you're
playing quite well yourself the two men
continue to play their moves becoming
more and more complex after a few
minutes Xavier makes a move that puts
Picard in Checkmate check mates
well played Charles thank you John Luke
handsome man shall we play again I'd be
delighted guys that was wonderful the
performances were spot on but the
Integrity of the AI is ruined if you
improvise so please please read only
what's on them I'm sorry so the good
news is we're now gonna let you guys
take control of the AI for every hundred
dollars that you reach out of your
little trash bag wallets oh my God we
will enter in the prompt of one of your
super chats so maybe we'll combine some
yeah we'll combine some maybe we'll do
mashups but we will enter the prompts
John will print out a script we will
perform for you we will dance for our
dollars today it's almost Christmas 100
of these proceeds go to me trying to
find my son he's 42 he ran away from
home because I'd like to reconnect with
him yes yes we're already getting some
super chats Christian unpronounceable
receiving compensation from Lufthansa
the Christian were you a part of the
Lufthansa Heist yeah did Henry Hill get
to you yeah what what happened uh also
Devin King dark rift Mr Feeney sending
in Super Chat yes Mr Phoenix
yeah
Jakarta Beck told Showdown again Jets
got the better of us last time I won't
deny
denial different in Buffalo let me break
down this week's game if you want to
know that you actually do mine
this is the house divided and we will
not get into it Devon King says Jess's
wife would I'll fight you for that
because like what are you doing okay the
title is very hard it's a challenge it's
a challenge that everyone has to fight
for the mantle is it waifu the like
emotionless pillows that you just
fondled
um don't talk about my wife like that
if so thanks I've had a very different
experience I guess but I can smack
around I get slapped I get yelled at hey
by who by my waifu that's yufu well we
can't get into all that but what we can
get into is our big discussion today uh
during ccxp which was the Comic-Con down
in Brazil this last weekend uh some of
the films cast along with Kevin feige
they were being interviewed uh about the
upcoming Ant-Man was quantumania and one
of the things that was brought up by
director Peyton Reed is how powerful the
this Kang is we don't know which king
this is but the king we're gonna see is
quite a powerful one he mentioned that
uh this King has dominion over time
obviously I would hope so uh but he also
said when speaking about how powerful he
is that he conserves his energy oh a
couch potato I see I guess so
I don't serve my energy today
[Applause]
to hang out with his Kang out stop
what's up
foreign
do you wanna do you wanna you wanna go
do something crazy and evil I'm just
hanging out with my Kang out today don't
worry about it you're just hanging
around hey so we were we were talking
around the office about this is kind of
a weird way to describe his power like
conserving his energy like he's like
he's biting his time he's waiting he's
waiting for the right moment to strike
uh and then we were thinking about
earlier footage that we've seen uh from
Ant-Man was quantumania at like d23
right there was a moment that was not in
the trailer that was put out where you
see Cassie Lang AKA stature I assume
she's gonna be stature in this like in a
Cell behind Kang it's that moment when
Kang is talking to Scott Lang uh Kang
delang and they're having a line which
has been changed multiple times as we've
seen it uh when it was at d23 Kang was
saying have fun how about have I killed
you before right as in he's faced
Avengers before he's killed them can't
remember it's been so many he's killed
ant-mans before right well Lang don't
leave him hanging hey
hey I didn't like you go down to his
domain and don't answers
do you want to switch spots the biggest
fan right now and I'm not having it so
you have a Kang you know who's like
maybe killed a bunch of Avengers before
his questioning Skyline about that and
then you put all this information
together with uh back at Comic-Con San
Diego 2022 summer so long ago Kevin
feige during an interview he was
pointing out how there's only two
Avengers films in Phase five or the next
two phases phase six but that a lot of
these films are team-up movies including
Ant-Man and the WASP quants man he
referred to it as a team up film now in
this trailer we've only seen the major
players that we know right we don't see
Hulk coming in we don't see a shangshi
zipping through the quantum realm or
anything like that he's just like
writing his Rings like right through it
like I'm coming
put me in coach
so we started we started putting all
this information together okay now hear
me out I'm hearing this is crazy it
doesn't look crazy okay if Cassie Lang
is getting locked up in a Cell he's got
these cells and he's biting his time
he's conserving his energies hanging out
with his hangout okay is he collecting
Avengers is he collecting like variants
of Avengers killing the ones he don't
need he don't need him he kills them but
the ones he do need he keeps he's making
a Kang chain he's making a Kang chain
gang
I like this idea because like he'd be
basically forcing them to do and using
them as tools he's like all right you
can come out because like I need to use
you either as like bait or like use you
to do attack I like that idea and what a
great kind of semicolon after Multiverse
of Madness leading us into Kang Dynasty
and and Secret Wars to have like oh
here's a Hawkeye variant in the quantum
realm that Kang needs for his like
Precision eyesight or whatever here's so
here we have a Hawkeye from another
another dimension or Another Universe
here we could even have potentially I
don't know we could get a Chris Evans
Cameo we could get Thor I feel like we
could definitely get a Chris Hemsworth
you know Hemsworth loves being Thor he
can show up we could get a lot we know
we know Loki variants are all over the
place
I like it I love the idea yeah if he if
Kang is like he has dominion over time
or whatever and he's in the quantum
realm and he's in this kind of Nexus
space where he can jump into other
multiverses and just grab what he needs
right but it is also weird because you
know the film is setting up that he's
trapped in a way right right like why
isn't he just coming out he has to use
this weird device to suck them in so is
he only pulling in people who are able
to access the quantum realm you're Mr
Fantastic he's missing he's unable maybe
to go travel maybe he's somehow lost his
ability to travel interdimensionally and
now the last piece of his uh his Kang
gang is the uh is is Ant-Man
yeah I honestly do think that we're
going to look at a scenario where
um Kang is trying to figure out the the
solution to grow big because we know
he's in the quantum realm and like he
shrinks down um Scott and his family and
he's like I need that that big juice how
did you do it how did you get to Giant
man because I need to go to giant man so
I can be regular size so I can conquer
your world because like I don't want to
be down here so like he needs that that
big juice I think the whatever makes
um giant man a giant man I think he
wants to steal I mean the blue particle
yeah right the blue particles the red
ones make you small yeah red rose make
you smile the blue ones make you big but
we'll drink it there that's what it was
in the movie Yes since when they get the
different colors no if I take a blue
pill and it makes me big for more than
two hours should I do that position yes
no you can go to four hours oh four
hours if it's hour five that that's when
the your brain starts using blood and
you start to faint yeah you call it Dr
nasty oh doctor nasty he makes his own
pills doctor he gives me a purple pill
and it does everything it gives me a
rainbow pill well who knows what happens
wait who is
is my lawyer Dr nasty uh is my is my is
my physician he gives me a pill it makes
me fall asleep for a week and when I
wake up my journals are vended anyway
Dr Matthew is also my adult star name
just kidding
if this is a Marvel team-up film as
Kevin feige has promised us and I will
hold him to it please uh who what
someone who you think would be most
likely to appear in this from from the
uuvoir of MCU characters you can have
everyone anyone except strong Chic I
mean we gotta I mean there are rumors
about this so I don't want to hear
nothing but okay Bishop
Young Avengers I think it'd be a really
great way to sort of tease that and be
like all right here's
um Kate bishop and like their friends
and like sort of like towards the end of
them I don't think that she's gonna be
like really involved because like this
is an Ant-Man movie but then again we do
know that
um uh Hawkeye had those pink Tech arrows
so like uh there is a relationship
between she could trip and fall on one
it's like whoops whoops whoops
so we we could be looking at a scenario
where um you know Scott and
um Hawkeye have a rapport like they're
probably he's probably the the closest
Avenger that he knows because like he's
regular like him and so uh yeah I feel
like there's a chance for Kate Bishop to
show up I it's just wishful thinking
really wishful thinking
heard a rumor that uh Scarlett Johansson
will be reprising her role as uh Black
Widow uh but she comes from a universe
where it's always 90 degrees in Miami
Beach so she's constantly just in a
bathing suit oh my goodness yeah that's
what I heard in my room Rebellion hey
Jessica is there anyone you want to see
in this film
um not that wait is that the snack Widow
vary
now I'm over it kitchen spots nice
I do think that if they're gonna do this
weird variant thing or like Pullins from
other universes it could bring back a
dead character yes that's what I mean
I don't think she's done I think you
know once she's settled I mean just
inside baseball industry when she
settled her dispute with Disney over the
release of Black Widow I'm sure that
opened the door they're like now that
we've paid her out we're gonna use well
they did I think she would turn away
they put out a storm wasn't there a
story that came out that like she has a
production deal with Disney yeah either
to produce or be in something else I I
don't get yeah get the feeling that she
probably wants to keep playing this
character I mean like I mean she did the
she got she got out of having to like be
in every single Avengers property but
like if she shows up in Kang's uh
Quantum realm prison that's gonna be a a
gas moment I want evil Hank Pam that's
what I'm oh that would be awesome I want
the guy from what if but like most tank
bims are evil right there uh 616 Hank
Pym is pretty uh evil uh yeah no it's
literally the the quantum what's it
called the pen particles that mess with
your brain and like when before we got
any footage I sort of thought that's
what quantumania meant oh it's like oh
you haven't gone crazy
there's a lot of interpretations if I
can give you more time and we we've
theorized maybe that Kang just tells
Scott how he dies and then he's like but
I could make it not be that way this is
true like what if the pin particles is
got them sick and he's just like I don't
want to tell Cassie and like I need more
time and like I would like that I mean
there is a theme of like time making you
insane and like and messing with time
like like with Fila and or Athena and
eternal right right like she was going
through just basically like a fractured
brain because she had been alive for so
long right the Mad weary the Mad weary
yeah yeah yeah uh I like all these ideas
I think it was great yeah I think there
is something terminal about Scotland in
this film and it I it could stretch back
to his first foray into the quantum
realm uh in end game when he got made
old and made young like that might have
really messed up himself has like a
cancer yeah yeah it's just like totally
and even uh it's a King sir but even
Janet can't even Janet in her glowing
hands camp fix it right but there's also
um I don't know if I'm I'm incorrect
here but like I wasn't Cassie sick in
the comics
oh maybe I think I don't know there was
a point where Cassie was sick and then
like
um Scott Lane needed to go like I don't
know steal money for her or something I
don't know but like maybe Cassie's sick
and like he needs to buy more time for
Cassie I don't know who knows it's
possible we need like a we need an AI
That's Just koi that has ready yeah boy
and Jessica we didn't make to put their
brains in the ass is there a comic run
where this thing happens yes I know this
one but you know a lot you're a freaking
genius
keep sending in those super chats so we
can get an AI scripture over halfway
there thank you match one four three
yeah saying so good to see our nerd Dad
yes I love you hashtag where are you all
right hold on Match 143 I'm looking at
you thank you I love you my nerd Side
Little Red Rose saying hi which movie
will be the part of Venom up here oh
like what do you think we'll see the
little Venom juice again oh Spiderman 4
and uh Venom three oh a Double Dipper
yes uh this is me asking have you all
watched Wednesday Ducks yes but I've
heard nothing but uh like everyone
everyone's talking about Jenna Ortega
and uh General
the world always it's always Jenna
Ortega sure Jenna um yeah I watched I
finished it sure yeah did you like it
yeah
right it's not The Adams Family what
could be eat me
eat me this Friday you may have heard uh
it's our big break room holiday party
hooray uh we're gonna be celebrating
with you all live right here on the air
and we're going to be making some
signature cocktails yes prepared by our
very own professional bartender Tabby
can can go the Kangal Bells absolutely
not uh Tommy's gonna Tommy's gonna be
making a couple signature cocktails here
the quantum Manhattan which is the
festive take on the classic Manhattan
Midwood cranberry thyme syrup from
Iconic cocktail company
why are those real alcohols well this is
just a mixer okay I'm glad you asked
iconic cocktail they make all sorts of
delicious cocktail mixers we're making a
really fancy cocktail at home without
needing to be a professional bartender
like Tommy before his license was taken
away from the state of California
but these uh premium ingredients and
mixers they make you can also make
mocktails uh because at our holiday
party you know we're all inclusive we're
gonna have a mocktail as well
if you will it's called the nowhere to
go uh we're gonna use their bitter
orange tonic and green tea in fact I've
been ordered to only drink the Moscow
while I'm working yeah and that is how
it's gonna go it will be our real break
room holiday party that's gonna roll
into our real new rock stars holiday
party right here in a break room which
that part you will not be a part of but
if you want to join us at the Holiday
party and make these cocktails yourself
at home if you order today from Iconic
cocktail today being the last day you
can get it by Friday uh and enjoy with
the uh enjoy it with us uh while we're
live on the air but you can also order
them anytime yeah and we have the
recipes for those cocktails I mentioned
in the description right now so check
those out uh and order today to order by
today uh and you can get some cranberry
thyme or bitter orange tonic from Iconic
of cocktails by Friday and drink along
with us during our holiday party let's
go order them whenever you want because
if you use our code new rockstars at
iconic cocktail.com you can get 20 off
your order that's right 20 off your
order and again these are just the
ingredients made with premium
ingredients premium mixers made by real
bartenders that's right you can make
alcoholic drinks you can make
non-alcoholic I use the vanilla uh and I
make it I put it in my coffee just my
regular coffee just a couple little
little spoonfuls of vanilla it helps the
coffee go down it's so good you guys and
you know I'm gonna be drinking that kind
of cocktails all Christmas break so even
if you don't get your ordering today use
the code that rock stars at iconic [ __ ]
sales iconic cocktails and drink like an
icon okay seriously be like me I'm gonna
be iconic oh holiday break I'm gonna be
iconically fun at Christmas morning when
they're like this guy's jacked up on
vanilla and coffee but yeah iconic
cocktails Christmas night at dinner this
guy's jacked up on cranberry time that's
right because I'm an icon and I use
iconic cocktails new rock stars at the
checkout drink like us be iconic yeah
iconic cocktail.com for recipes
education and more oh and they can find
the recipes
no it's a good reminder go to the
description of this video the recipes
for the drinks will be there you can
also watch me making them live with a
smile on my face forgetting about all
those years I bartended the places I
hated
hooray yeah hooray I love cocktails
um you guys we have some new updates
okay for Daredevil reborn is going to be
the series Daredevil born again was
originally the title right again I think
it's what they're calling both of it
yeah I thought they'd change the title I
think it's still born again okay let's
go off born again you guys know we'll do
Born Again Daredevil born again so
Margarita leviva and I might have
pronounced that wrong and I'm so sorry
from the deuce and Sandrine Holt from
American Gigolo which also Stars Jay
Washington
are set for major roles opposite of
Charlie Cox and Vincent D'Onofrio and
Daredevil born again and the rumor has
it rumor has it
rumor has it that they will be playing
the love interest for Daredevil and
Wilson hello
okay yeah so there's I mean there's a
lot of stuff
series to the Disney plus that they're
not gonna keep in so this could be
potential that like a the girl could one
of their Devil's lovers could be Elektra
yes yes but I don't think it's Karen
Page right yeah I don't think they're
gonna play Karen Page uh because we were
looking at it we're expecting that uh
Margarita La Viva is gonna be Charlie
Cox's love interest then Sandra no it's
the other one yeah I think the other way
I was going to get into this okay so I
but I was I was answering this part
first yeah the biggest part is Wilson
fisk's lover because we know Wilson
fisk's number one level will always be
Vanessa Vanessa
so we can expect that that one could be
Vanessa and we also know that Michael
Gandolfini is going to be uh that was
just casted recently in an undisclosed
role but everyone thinks it might be his
son Wilson's son it makes sense I mean
this is James gandolfini's son yeah it's
a lot like James Gandolfini he was in
Saints of New York yeah
this isn't a joke around show Mt gets
serious but yeah it seems like he's
gonna be Richard uh uh Wilson fist's son
yeah so or I think he's been named
something else in other Comics but I
think that he's gonna play with his son
and do you want to do your impression
I'm dick fist never mind
it's every morning just like my papa
um and so uh when news got out
gandalfine they'd be playing it was
casted Vincent didn't offer responded
and we have a photo of it it's ages of
fandom tweeted this and they tagged in
uh I think the Hollywood report or a
variety Variety in the Winston Offroad
underneath says I'm very happy I'm very
happy about this I'm happy he's playing
my son damn it I wasn't supposed to uh
and they're in an older Daredevil comic
there was actually a storyline where
Vanessa leaves Wilson Fisk but comes
back to New York because she finds out
that her son is trying to kill him yeah
and she kills her son yeah oh my God
she's like oh uh Wilson's gonna be
pissed about this yes
oh boy hey uh we crossed the Super Chat
total I know we haven't finished this oh
my God but I have not seen uh a lot of
suggestions for potential fights in the
super chats so I'm just gonna wing one
here based on a soup
you can bring it out right now he's
crunching it and then we can jump back
in we'll we'll have uh we'll have an
update of an AI script for you soon oh
oh John's Flying AI
the AI is making its noise uh yeah thank
you to our super Chatters dark rift
calling out T Michael Beck told us
bartender I cannot have that guy's
prompt oh okay girl thank you Quinton
Bucky Barnes ATL film juice free girl
dark rift match 14. oh now you want to
do it thank you for super chats just
kidding yeah um is someone gonna read
the uh film juices
okay I'll read descriptions so the
prompt The Prompt this is fresh from the
AI The Prompt is this is a script of
Steve Rogers and Peggy Carter's first
conversation after he returns from the
future
go ahead
Peggy Steve it's so good to see you you
too I can't believe you're here neither
can I so what happened it's a long story
I was frozen in ice for a long time and
then I was brought back to the present
that's incredible I've been allowed to
take I'm sure I've missed you so much
I've missed you too I'm so glad I'm back
me too do you want to have sex in 1950s
I'm sorry I can't
I'm a PG-13 kid that actually says in a
descript oh that's too bad I have to go
back to the future can I come with you
no thank you what what
no thank you what a Twist I will say I
will say uh John did you just write that
I will say the woman asking can I come
with you and the man saying No thank you
is very 1950s Style sex so I would say
that yes wow uh oh oh my God that's a
pretty good that's a nice thing that's a
pretty good AI that's really good guys
if you want to hear another one we're
just
83.50 away
[Music]
because this is chaos no I was gonna ask
do you want me to keep going yeah yeah
let's talk about let's talk about more
about this casting news so the fact that
uh the so again Daredevil born again the
uh the comic book series is completely
horrific uh it's frankly Frank Miller so
it's very dark they do Karen rough in
that one yeah oh yeah well her
introduction in the Netflix series was
not exactly like a all cake tonight
right yes yeah well I guess she wasn't
like she's like a heroin addict in um in
the comics she gets like deeper yeah
yeah uh in the comics he gets really
deep in the Karen and she kind of messes
over
um Daredevil a couple of times she's
like she like sells them out basically
yeah and then he still forgives her but
like what is
so I don't think necessarily and I think
a lot of people know that Daredevil born
again isn't going to be the Disney
version isn't going to be so closely
tied to the Netflix series because so
much of that stuff Sans Karen being
addicted and selling them out is
actually from the comic book straight to
Netflix season three yeah they've seen
some of it yeah yeah so I think it would
be a good idea to steal this little
comic book tidbit of Vanessa having to
kill Michael I do like that I mean
Vanessa is a big part of Wilson fisk's
life uh it was important in uh the
Netflix series it was important across
the spider verse like in that or yes in
that storyline uh Wilson Fisk had like
lost his his wife and son and was
ripping open the multi-first to find a
version of them right and like steal
them and bring them into him to his uh
his his universe so we know it's that
kind of fearless character now the twist
here the twist uh if they're pulling out
we know they've pulled this two
characters from Netflix or from the
Netflix version Kingpin and Daredevil
right uh and we're saying they can't
take everyone no right it's too messy
they've done all these story lines they
would kind of conflict so do we think
this is like a new Vanessa are they
gonna set her you think they'll set her
up as like a Vanessa that's been there
from the beginning of Vanessa Varian is
he just beating this Vanessa for the
first time I would love her to be a
Vanessa variant or a Vanessa scroll but
I don't think we're gonna get another
origin story I think they're kind of
tired of that right because they're like
we don't need to do this again
um everybody knows Vanessa is married to
Wilson yes Disney plus Daredevil though
is probably going to have a little more
uh Supernatural or not Supernatural but
like Fantastical elements to it right I
mean Defenders had a little bit of that
but like Daredevil was pretty grounded
it was like a lot of fighting and like
you know actual weapon fighting I feel
like we could see squirrels in this
maybe I don't know it doesn't seem that
far freshers 19 episodes where fresh my
memory during Hawk guy it's implied that
Kingpin didn't get dusted because he
helps out no wow was not the thing in
Hawkeye he was he helps out Kate
Bishop's mom but that's post the uh
attack on New York and I'm trying so
hard to not say this was in something
else but wasn't the the thing was Wilson
fist didn't snap and he had time to like
kind of own New York while everyone was
kind of gone I think we remember
theorizing that what does that look like
he was you know he's wearing the
Hawaiian shirt yeah he's running and
gunning out of like a tire shop like
he's down on his luck maybe and I'm
wondering if if he was snapped in
Vanessa wasn't did she find out
everything that was going on in his
absence and is now he's come back and
she's like I'm out of here it depends on
which Vanessa we're going to be fair I'm
genuinely really sick and tired of like
uh obviously like gullible Vanessa sure
she should clearly she would absolutely
know what Wilson Fisk is up to so I
would love for this Disney version of
Vanessa to be like I'm in on the books
too right like unless
yeah Vanessa at first was like oh I
don't want to be a part of this and she
was like you know what I do okay
yeah yeah I want to watch you uh smash a
guy's head in the door one more time
with the car yeah the car what if we're
looking at a scenario where
um like Fisk was snaps but his son took
over the Empire
and then like he's sort of like trying
to get his again now dad's back he's
like he's like I don't need you Daddy
exactly sorry Dad dick Fisk runs these
neck of the woods exactly you're the
young you're the youngest son that's why
you haven't taken over here James little
Timmy fists a little succession style
taking over the company Roman Fisk it
feels very narcosy and I I like that
because it still plays into like a
criminal drug lord yeah so I like the
idea of like the sun being like no I'm
still running this like or this is my
dad's operation I'm involved right you
know like the fist family like he Fisk
like killed his dad yeah and like so
like it would be really interesting to
see like his dynamic with his son and
like how his son wants to kill him it'd
be really fun you could never trust your
son he's never heard of you anymore I'm
gonna swerve here I'm gonna zag you guys
are you guys are all saying Gandalf
Randolph he's definitely son I think
he's owl man I think we got a chance for
owls leaving to come back now and come
back to life if we're rebooting yeah so
uh John will you bring back up the photo
sorry he showed this for you yeah
can you show me the thirsty thespians
there's also rumors
look at that creamy font so disturbing
oh no it's just water there's also
there's a Touchback version
all he does is play characters in
flashbacks
real quick I mean you said we kind of
glanced around this other actor playing
the love interest for Charlie Cox maybe
not Elektra I mean it could be if they
really want it I would hope they would
say we're casting this person as a watch
uh probably not Karen Page because I
think the fan I think a lot of fans are
like I don't do that yeah she's they're
the two people yeah there are other
characters out there that he's been
romantically involved with over the
years I mean some strange ones like moon
dragon uh he was involved with he was
involved with a black cat for a little
bit trying to make Spider-Man jealous I
don't think he was involved with Hellcat
but she does resemble Hellcat yeah so
that could be something and Hellcat
isn't notorious uh a woman and I forget
her name I apologize if you know the
answer call in uh who was a district
attorney in L.A who he had a
relationship with
Barnes uh I think it's both Selena and
Barnes
and this this character knew he was
Daredevil because she was very smart and
she sussed it out very easily like
everyone you come home with bullets in
your chest right but that would be
interesting twist knowing that they've
kind of you know shipped uh She-Hulk and
um Daredevil already and you have this
uh West Coast connection if he somehow
meets another lawyer and it's like well
I'm in New York right now I can do
whatever I want oh my God different area
codes
make him a bad dude put him on the next
season of White Lotus let's see what
happens you're doing Matt Murdock
activities with your Matt Murdoch
Tendencies Matt muradox are your friends
Matt Murdoch's are your enemies
Theodore hair is I love that thank you
Tommy Theodore Harris said in
um the comic run Richard fist teamed up
with hobgoblin the challenge kingpins
Empire
Ned coming in
it's got to happen it's gonna happen
there's no way it's not gonna happen
oh he wants to take the battle is going
to get shredded one day and like we're
all gonna respect he doesn't gotta be
shredded Mickey Mouse yeah that'd be
great but like I can tell like he's he's
gonna get shredded one a little thing
more maybe he will maybe he will
um well I'm excited to see this show
yeah one more Daredevil I will say being
in La Comic-Con this weekend lots of
daredevils
Daredevils are trying to overtake Spider
Boys
okay what was the Daredevil Deadpool
ratio you don't want to see that mini
dead price I saw a aerial
that was very funny I saw the pirate
Deadpool yeah but I think I'm not
noticing the Deadpool your brain is
blocking it
in now for years Deadpool was the go-to
Comic-Con costume because it was like
yeah you could dress up and you have a
mask on and you can be like oh yeah
oh yeah and now it's like that and also
I think a lot okay two things cons when
people dress up as Deadpool they just
like to do Deadpool as someone else so
they'll do Deadpool Spider-Man or
Deadpool Cinderella Deadpool whatever
but also at La Comic-Con I knows that
people are going very hard in the paint
with their outfits they were like I paid
tons of money for this and I want to do
it with my best friend there's also
going to be Daredevil just from season
two people have 3D printers at home now
and they can make these so much good
armor and by the way after our smash
success standing room only panel at La
Comic-Con maybe work for our next con
which who knows where it's going to be
if you want us to come to your con you
let them know to bring the break room
fan family and you want to know we ain't
coming
cheaper hotels and hot dogs
play a game and we may have to come in
with some premium costumes
at all times I'm talking about her I'm
talking about every time I go to a con I
go as a scroll imitating me yeah that's
how I do it you're like the guy that
went to the Halloween party he's like
I'm a dad
I'm an Abercrombie model you know what
that's gonna be like I'm George Foreman
because I'm bald
this is by a George Foreman you should
just yeah just bring a grill and be like
who wants a sausage I'll have a box of
gloves
who wants a free a flash freeze rib
absolutely not
yeah it's just
I I can show you light skin
oh I got it it only worked for being
empty in the Black Box
oh no you don't have to follow all I
gotta say to that is
XP and that Ant-Man is
way too far during that Ant-Man uh in
the WASP quantumania interview uh there
was a little more info uh interesting
information that came out when they were
talking to Kevin feige during the
interview uh he had something
interesting to say about the character
of Ant-Man and where the story is right
now Jack do we have a clip of that uh
what he says is incredibly interesting
it's so fascinating it's gonna blow your
back out
oh John we're not doing a good job
oh you know what guys I had a dream last
night dreams are always fun to explain
yes and in this dream I had wet my pants
and I was concerned that in real life
and I'll be honest I'm happy to say I
was dry all night
these amazing people that we've been
with now for eight years starting with
Ant-Man ended phase two and now kicking
off phase five in such a huge way much
like Scott Lang himself going from you
know this this Petty criminal in uh
coming out of jail to see his daughter
to saving the world in endgame I love
that the Ant-Man franchise is now at the
peak of the MCU and kicking off phase
five of the MCU wow this is our first
film in Phase five I got I nailed all
those F's uh that was Kevin feige in the
Hat yes would you let him hit uh me yeah
he's driving wait hang on hang on let me
try something the light skin gray oh
no I don't know does he not honey it's
okay just keep going he's got he's all
right
do I need to apologize he just raised
his pants uh got a white skin ribs oh my
gosh oh that works in my pants peek a
phase five at the as the first film yes
is that like a a good thing well I think
it makes me think the rest is downhill
what he's saying is now after all the
dust has settled on phases one through
four yeah we are reaching Ant-Man
quantumania and that is the top like I
think he likes to say everything is an
evolution right I think is an escalation
so now Ant-Man is the top dog and it's
kicking off phase five which is only
gonna go higher I think I think he was
trying to be rah-rah but in the way that
he phrase it it almost sounded like this
is the best we got guys it did come off
like that I didn't like it well I do
appreciate as as a big fan of both of
the Ant-Man films I feel like they get a
lot of oh you're okay they get a lot of
not hate but they're they're put up at
the bottom of lists for people sometimes
especially the second one which you know
it is a masterpiece it's so good it is
great and I like it and it has great
stuff in it and I'm excited I'm excited
to have ghosts I like it more than the
first one I think I'd have ghosts coming
back yeah Thunderbolts even with that
stuff just like just regarding ghosts
it's still like this guy saved us and I
think that's the part that it's like
he's important because of that and
that's why his story is like he put a
building in a briefcase and walked away
with him could you do that did you do
that could you do that I've done it once
and it wasn't even that impressive it
was just a Dairy Queen so I think the
master Remains the Same I don't
understand how they moved that building
but that's that's neither here nor there
but I do appreciate that this character
is getting a lot of shine uh Ant-Man you
know it it it was there to provide
comedic relief for in between a lot of
these movies which are a lot more heavy
uh and the character is powerful and
Ant-Man is the one who's like still on
Earth doing his job I don't know what
his job is but he's doing it he's out of
here he's going around having kids all
over the universe Thor he doesn't give a
crap about Earth anymore he's leaving
his people behind yeah uh uh Doctor
Strange he meets the lady on the street
he goes into a dark hole with her hey
hey I mean I do it too you don't get it
wrong you know he's just like oh I'm
sorry I'm not gonna tell anyone I'm
leaving I'm just leaving right well can
I can I ask a question again once again
take a little crud out of my nerd wallet
and they're not a sponsor but you know
what I mean my nerd savings account did
uh Goliath die the guy who played Bill
he did not die in two right he was
revealed to be kind of the bad guy right
he was he was helping ghost because he
felt bad that Shield took advantage of
it oh Lawrence Fishburne yeah and he was
somewhat felt responsible for the death
of her father that's right it's been a
while
right watches uh this is a separate
conversation anyway this is what I'm
saying uh I think Goliath needs to come
back in this movie I think oh yeah
also Fisheries out of the Matrix he's
not doing the Matrix movies anymore they
replaced himself smart move get out you
know he's not voicing Silver Surfer
ostensibly we don't know no and if
they're never gonna green light season
four of Hannibal which is a travesty but
you're still think great show Bring It
Back bring it back Hannibal come on the
break room uh I do see someone in the
chat pointed out and they did ask what
tea do you use for the nowhere to go I
think you can use a tea of your your
this was the the mac oh yes we're using
uh green we're using a green we're using
a green tea we're using a green tea for
the know where to go I think just give
it a little alien feel yeah but you can
use a black tea you can use
it
I personally my favorite tea is a lap
saying sushang which is a tea that is
cured over a smoky firewood gives the
tea a nice Smoky flavor as Winston
Churchill's favorite tea because it
smells like oh my God you know what my
favorite tea is what's your favorite tea
the hot tea
and I'm very sad well you know you are
the better favorite team I'm sorry you
know what my favorite tea is a T-Rex
maybe you know it's actually a smooth
movement or a sleepy time I like
medicinal teas I like chamomile
chamomile tea will will help you if you
have stomach problems with like I do so
yes this has been tea time with the tea
boys I like Lipton
uh but I am I'm very excited for him the
WASP Quantum I'm excited for phase five
now that we're through phase four and
it's epilogue uh I want to keep it all
going uh I think it's going to be great
the housing on Days Are Here folks let's
enjoy it it's almost Christmas time and
when you're writing that fat man a
letter you let him know you want the MCU
to drop another trailer for us yes give
us Loki we need that Loki season two
trailer what the heck we've got lots of
announces somewhere all the time and
it's day two this week guys we have some
excited I know we're not done yet I'm
just saying we got to say stuff we're
gonna be doing a little secret Santa
from the break room cast on Friday I
gotta buy a gift uh it's over we'll take
care of it uh we're gonna do a little
secret santa exchange you know a little
fun for us you know we may have some
more surprises Friday's gonna be very
fun yeah uh really get into the season
if you know what I'm saying not just
Christmas all holidays Hanukkah Kwanzaa
Festivus any Satanic rituals you guys do
writing holidays I mean you know the you
know Christmas was really put on our
pagan holiday and really took it away
from them you want me to rip the
chicken's head off on the air I'll do it
you know I have no problem hurting a dog
they were decorating trees for health
and wellness the Christians noticed and
was like Christmas I mean for those of
you that are atheists we'll just hold up
a blank sheet of paper and complete
silence okay okay all right okay uh but
yeah make sure you tune in on Friday
we're gonna be having a lot of fun
having our holiday party get your orders
in today at iconic cocktails.com and you
can get your mixers in time for the
party but get them whenever again 20 off
using Code drink with us in the party
thank you iconic cocktails for this
shirt Tommy's wearing this shirt we're
having a great time so comfy uh make
sure you like And subscribe if you
haven't already like this like the show
uh we thank you all for joining us today
let's get a bunch of ants in the chat
for Ant-Man yeah and thank you to
everyone who said super chats yeah yeah
trash bag Theodore Harris swilling is
that women
I think it's the the the The Lion King
the oh it does look like the little uh
Simba oh yeah
uh the King has returned
thank you all for tuning in today join
us here tomorrow at the same time uh
Tommy and Jessica's breakdown of the
transparent trailers out on the channel
now and it is burning up it's so fun it
is great make sure you check it out plus
we've got Anna breaking down more Super
Mario Brothers movie footage that's not
already out it will be coming out uh
today tomorrow I take that back I think
we might try to get out today we'll see
how it goes don't fight off uh and Paul
little pointing out if you need thoughts
or on mocktails or iced tea talk to me
those are my jams not actual Jam uh
we'll see you guys here tomorrow same
time same channel right here in the
video of all of you love your Breakers
roomies trash bags all have a great rest
of your day my escape
games Miss Morgan
foreign
[Music]